- Alright, let's see.
What! Shut the (beep) up!
(funky music)
- Hey, I'm Zack, and today I am taking a bath in champagne
to see if I can get drunk through my skin.
Why champagne?
Because champagne is the highest proof alcohol
that Buzzfeed's legal team would allow us to do.
Also, I like bubbles.
There's not a lot of research
on whether or not you can absorb alcohol through your skin,
so we're going to do this for you, for science.
I've got some friends here to help,
put champagne on me.
Keith, we got Shane, looks like Annie's here,
this is my best friend Ben from New York.
Ben is a doctor and has informed me
that I should be concerned about a UTI,
because, uh, alcohol has sugars,
and sugars in your pee-pee hole is a bad time.
So I'm wearing a condom, and I've rapped it
with rubber bands, this is a very confusing day.
Don't zoom in, don't do that.
But first, to prove that I am not yet drunk,
I am going to take a Breathalyzer.
I didn't have enough breath.
Well, it's zeroes, let's just trust that, huh?
Let's do it!
I mean, let's take our clothes off.
I am, potentially, a little worried.
I'm mostly just worried that it's going to stain.
But, you know, it's Friday, so let's party.
Who wants to pour stuff on me?
(funky music)
- [Woman's Voice] Don't drink any, it's not scientific!
- Sorry, I spit it out.
I'm not drunk yet, but this is definitely
a weird fever dream.
(laughs)
- I don't know, I feel great.
- [Man's Voice] Yeah?
- I feel very relaxed.
- [Man's Voice] Should we Breathalyze him now?
- [Woman's Voice] Yeah, let's do a Breathalyzer.
- Alright, let's see.
What! Shut the (beep) up!
- [Man's Voice] It says .063.
- It says "danger".
(laughing)
- [Man's Voice] However, there's a lot of fumes in the air.
- There's a lot of fumes, it's like, beeping "danger".
- [Man's Voice] Maybe you're butt-chugging on accident.
- [Man In Green] One. It's in the caution level,
and there's a frowny face blinking.
- [Zack] It's really hard right now to know if this is
a placebo or real, but I definitely feel, I feel loopy.
- [Man In Green] Yeah?
- Uh-huh.
- We basically, right now we're trying to see,
is the Breathalyzer picking up on me
or is it just picking up on this.
So Keith is joining me, he's a good bud.
- I'm going to let the fumes get into my mouth.
- Alright, take a Breathalyzer.
- [Zack] My testicles, uh, feel tingly.
- .39?
Not 039, either?
.39?
I'm dead!
I'm dead at this point.
Through our experimentation, we found that anyone
who Breathalyzes right here, it will read way too high.
So we're going to take Zack, get him out of this tub,
douse him with water,
so he doesn't have any fumes on his own body,
and Breathalyze him.
And that should tell us, definitively,
if he's drunk or not.
- Oh it's so cold!
- [Keith] Stop jumping away from it!
- Well, stop making it bad!.
- [Keith] Pretend it's a shampoo commercial.
- I'm your venus.
- [Keith] That's a shaving commercial.
- I'm your fire.
I'm really hoping that I'm at least a little something.
- .02
- (beep) yeah! We did it, America.
- It does seem like his body did absorb some alcohol.
- So, what did we learn here today?
Very exciting, this is a definitive piece
of scientific literature from this point forward.
So my takeaways here are:
if you have $300 and a lot of friends,
then you too can barely get tipsy in a bathtub.
- Yeah, I guess this is not a very
economical way to get drunk.
(funky music)
(yelling)